are you excited to graduate from college
but worried
that you might have to interact with
people whose race
and wealth differs from your own well
if you've got this anxiety if you wake
up in the middle of the night in a cold
sweat thinking about this
columbia university has the answer for
you they are
holding six multicultural
segregated graduation ceremonies
because i think that's the best way to
show those rich
white racists uh is to uh separate them
from all the other races
and all the other income groups that is
segregation for
social justice i'm michael noel's the
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from
fernando diaz-7 who says
he's pretty sure don lemon is not
catholic so why does he care
about what the pope says on marriage why
doesn't he speak up on what other
religions have to say
for example islam ah you've realized
what this is all about
you've you've seen what this is all
really about when there are attacks
on christianity broadly and specifically
on the catholic church
it is usually not because of the actual
issue at stake it is usually
simply an attack on the church
as the basis of and
an avatar for the west so
the koran says that if people commit
homosexual acts they should be
punished and harmed doesn't matter
actually ironically what you'll often
see
is the left embracing islamists
it's always as part of a broader attack
on the west this is how you could have
people like linda sarsour
holding hands with gloria steinem at the
women's march
these two gals might have pretty
different views of the world but
they both dislike the west they want to
upend our culture and so they're going
to join together
this is what you see in the process of
political correctness on the one hand
we're told
yes sex is totally fixed and if you've
got certain desires you can't change
them
born this way that's why we have to get
rid of the old definition of marriage
then at the next breath they'll say
actually there's no such thing as sex
men can become women it doesn't matter
but that's why
also we need to get rid of our old ideas
about sex and marriage
opposite ideas but it's a purely
negative
campaign to attack the west can't take
it at face value because it's not in
good
faith you know who also do not act in
good faith cyber criminals which is why
you gotta check out
lifelock the irs issued an urgent
warning about a new scam to steal the
electronic filing identification numbers
from tax professionals over email
cyber criminals can use this information
to file fraudulent tax returns
tax professionals should be aware of the
latest phishing scams but individuals
also should take steps to protect
themselves it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft
are affecting our lives lifelock helps
detect a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number for
sale on the dark web if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised
they will send you an alert i used to
think this kind of stuff doesn't matter
now look if you've been watching the way
that
technology has developed and technology
companies have developed over the past
couple years
and you still don't believe cyber
security is a big problem demanding your
attention i don't know if i can help you
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but you can keep what's yours with
lifelock identity theft protection
join now save up to 25 off your first
year
by going to lifelock.com slash knowles
can wlas
that's lifelock.com knowles to save 25
columbia really is hosting
six separate graduation ceremonies to
segregate students based on their race
and their wealth now from what i gather
this year the
graduation ceremony is going to be the
commencement ceremony
is going to be online it's going to be
on zoom so people are going to be paying
those exorbitant fees
as they have for a year and they're not
going to be getting in-person education
they're going to be
they've completed their zoom year now
they're going to have a zoom graduation
the the university is now trying to
clarify what exactly is going on so they
they released a statement
pointing out that these graduation
ceremonies exist
in addition to not instead of
university-wide commencement and
individual school class days
these events are voluntary and they're
open to every student
now how does that make any sense what do
you mean they're open to every student
they are
segregated on the basis of race and
income but they're open to every student
and i guess
legally this has to be true so they'll
say yes you know the black student
graduation
is open to every student but do you
think that if you're a white guy
and you show up to the black student
graduation that you're going to be
welcomed into that event no probably not
you as a legal matter
they might have to let you in but the
whole point of the event is to exclude
people
of other races but that's not legal
so they have to have these little
caveats i think it's the sort of way
that
if if i were at college right now and i
wanted to join the
african-american center or the latino
sen i don't know the latinx now i guess
is what it's called or la raza is what
it used to be called
uh talk about racism that's like the
organization called the race
but if i wanted to join one of these
ethnic interest groups
i think legally they have to let me in
because we're in this country not not
supposed to have racial discrimination
certainly at a publicly funded places
but as a practical matter you know
something tells me i'm not getting
elected
president of the afm house or or
chairman of la raza
uh also the fact that this is voluntary
and it's in addition to
how does this make it any better
i guess marginally it makes it better
but it's still so
degraded i remember this from my own
graduation from college which was not
that long ago i graduated
i guess it was kind of long ago now nine
years ago i
was there you know all the students are
there and all the different dorms and
residential colleges and different
schools and i noticed some students had
on these weird
shawls and some one was in a sort of
kente print a sort of african type print
and that one was the most obvious
because you noticed it was black
students wearing the kente print
not all black students but everyone who
was wearing the print was a black
student
and you know some other people had
different kind of shoals on and i
thought is that a particular
you know honor society is that a
particular distinction maybe if you
graduated
[ __ ] laude or this or that then i
realized no
the shoals that you that these people
were wearing at their graduation
were not representative of any academic
achievement whatsoever
they were just representative of race
and you think my goodness gracious you
go to a place like columbia
you know you get in it's not an easy
school to get into all these ivy league
schools are much much harder to get into
than they than they are to graduate
once you're in you basically can do
whatever you want i was told when i was
interviewing for college
that it would take an act of violence to
be booted out of a place like yale
or harvard and i think that's probably
true but still you know whatever you got
into it you know you made it all the way
through
and you've gone through all your courses
and you've done all your work and maybe
you've worked
a job and you right you've achieved
something hopefully
at least it used to stand for something
and
at your graduation day the thing you
most want to focus on
the thing you're you're most proud of
you're wearing it in front of you
is the color of your skin that is so sad
it's so pathetic
and they were doing this at the
universities
years ago i mean now you know nine ten
years ago
how much crazier this has gotten now
that there are separate graduation
ceremonies they're really really
offensive to consider
the most important aspect of one's
character be to be one's race
but this is all we hear there was a new
breaking news headline
that uh we now have our first native
american
cabinet secretary wow deb holland
has been approved by the senate to lead
the u.s department of the interior
this is part of joe biden's campaign to
quote ensure tribes have a seat at the
table at the highest levels of the
federal government by the way joe
i think that ship sailed okay i think
it's a
little too little too late if we're
talking about uh treaties with the
native americans
but this is being pushed as a sort of
woke moment we
finally isn't it about damn time that we
have a native american cabinet secretary
except we've already had not a native
american cabinet secretary we had a
native american vice president
almost 100 years ago charles curtis
vice president from 1929-1933
senate majority leader before that
congressman before that
a republican i would note this was not
considered a huge
breakthrough at the time charles
curtis's native american
ancestry and tribal claims
and physical appearance the guy looked
like a native american
that was not considered particularly
important
he had his he put his importance in what
he did in what he accomplished in his
career
but because we've become so frivolous as
a society
we no longer do that it's all just me me
me it has nothing to do with our actions
it's just our own
our own inner sense of virtue that we
can only really trace to our
most superficial physical
characteristics but this is part of a
larger strategy
of indoctrination and it is taking place
on university campuses at some of the
top university campuses in the country
yeah the young americas foundation with
whom i
i do my campus speaking tour back when
campus speaking tours still existed
hopefully they're going to start again
now that
the psycho politicians are letting
people go back to school
yaf just uncovered a video this comes
from
princeton theological seminary that
shows
just a little bit of the
diversity re-education classes
that all these students are being
subjected to
dr ibram x kindy states the work of
anti-racism
is to identify describe and dismantle
wherever you are in the continuum the
two pandemics demand
that we reimagine our society and indeed
our seminary
beyond our current structures and
practices i also think that
knowing that every member of our
institution
has committed themselves to this work
offers a powerful testimony
to our broader seminary community that
we recognize
anti-racism formation is a critical
component
of christian discipleship and witness
and that this work
of doing justice is ongoing i think
the anti-racism affirms a holistic
theology
right it acknowledges and when we
acknowledge
that this is an issue that's part of our
theological understanding
that it's part of our theology and
practices
for the future of the church what a gift
i'm excited that it's not a program
that it's being embedded as a way of
life
in our company community understanding
there it is not just a program not just
a course not just something you tell
like hey don't be a jerk to people of
other races
it is being embedded it is being made
this sort of
central fact and this at princeton
theological seminary right so they're
supposed to be studying religion and
what is what is
true about it is uh racism is an
affront to human dignity you know to
hate people on the basis of their race
is an affront to human dignity and
that's why it's wrong
it's not the center of
the christian faith this is not the
center of religious life
chesterton famously said that uh heresy
is not the promotion of vice
over virtue but it's the promotion of
one virtue to the exclusion of all the
others that's how i feel about the
anti-racism thing i'm not
i'm not even totally going to just
dismiss it out of hand i do want to take
the idea seriously and i do think
that there is such a thing as hatred for
people based on their race and i do and
i do think that's wrong and you know we
should
we shouldn't do that that's
makes perfect sense but to make that the
center to make that the idol of your
religion
is to lose your religion this is the
problem you know when you make idols out
of these things that are good
in their proper place then you you
distort
our view of the world the state is a
good thing right the state gives us law
and order and that's how we all get
along in society
but when you exalt that into an idol you
get statism
uh we've uh free markets for instance
that's a good
thing uh as an instrument to human
flourishing
individuality good thing to human
flourishing but when you make an idol
out of it you get individualism right
you so you don't want you want these
things in their proper place
this is part of a strategy that the left
is using
to upend our our society and it's taking
place
largely at the universities
and it uh it doesn't have very much to
do with reality
you'll notice there's a big divergence
between what we're being told this is a
white supremacist horrible country all
the black people are being killed
they're being hunted down
as a famous athlete said every time they
leave their homes
and the reality of it we'll we'll get
into the reality of that in just
one second but first you know you might
wonder why i look so rested why i feel
so good in the morning
it's because of bowling branch bowling
branch
makes the absolute softest organic
sheets on the market
bar none that's it punto bast as we say
in italian
comfort is not their only standard they
use 100 sustainable raw materials
the signature hemmed sheets from bowling
branch are a bestseller for a reason
uh they're not too hot they're not too
cool the perfect year-round sheets for
most
sleepers i on occasion have gotten to
stay
at very nice high-end hotels almost
exclusively when someone else is picking
up the tab but i've gotten to do it the
first thing i noticed about really nice
high-end hotels
is the sheets it's the bedding it's just
better me especially my bachelor days i
would basically sleep on sandpaper
whatever the cheapest sheets were
then i tried bowling branch bowling
branch is like sleeping at a five star
hotel every single night
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt bowlingbranch.com
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code michael at checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch
dot com put in promo code michael you
will
not regret it i promise you it's gonna
be the greatest sheets you've ever slept
on bowlin branch.com promo code michael
do you want to know what
institutional racism really looks like
right we're always told about
institutional racism and that's like
they mean anti-black racism specifically
or anti-mexican or anti-indian or
whatever
i'm referring to the native americans
not the other but i guess the other
indians do
you realize of course that the left
controls all of the institutions right
big tech higher education lower
education the administrative state on
and on hollywood right
so if they control all the institutions
and there is institutional racism that
would be a problem for the left
and we see this in the media here's some
institutional racism there's a story
just came out of rochester
two black teens uh burned and mentally
ill white guy to death
rochester new york the two black teens
have been charged with assault
and arson i'm not sure if they were
charged with murder
uh they sn snuck into the guy's home on
friday afternoon
they sprayed him with an ignitable fluid
and they set him on fire
until 70 of his body was covered in
second degree burns
then they left him to die but thankfully
a a man maybe it might have been a
mailman or a worker who was checking on
the gas in the electric
uh came into the apartment tried to put
put him out
put the the guy who was on fire put him
out by the time 911 got there though it
was too late
uh the the victim fought for his life
for four days in a burn
trauma unit and then he died a police
source
has confirmed the original reporting
which came from bob lonsberry
has confirmed that to the daily wire
you probably haven't heard of this story
if the races were reversed
this would be a national actually an
international news story
and the teens would be called white
supremacists
and they would certainly go to prison
for life
and likely receive the death penalty
uh this there would be marches in the
streets there would if
2020 is any indication there would be
riots all over the streets
stores would be broken into people would
be stealing private property in the name
of social justice
cities would be on fire but the races
are reversed here
so not only is none of that happening
but none of that's happening in large
part well
none of it would happen anyway but one
of the reasons none of it's happening is
because the media just won't cover it
are these kids being charged with a hate
crime i don't know what is a hate hate
crime
sort of a silly phrase it's a silly idea
the idea that you know certain crimes
are hate crimes so presumably other
crimes are love crimes
i don't i don't know about that student
crimes are lukewarm crimes maybe
but the idea that you should receive a
harsher sentence because of your
motivations
that somehow the jury will be able to
discern with
specificity all of your motivations and
then be able to meet out adjust
punishment based on that
you're not hearing about any of that
it's going to be swept
under the rug was it racist
maybe certainly psychopathic
why these two teenagers are going to be
permitted into society ever again is
beyond me
but that's the society that we live in
here's another story this one came
out of the tennessean you know now i am
a tennessean
here in nashville so i saw this story
mom says woman killed in police shootout
had troubled
childhood no opportunity for change
now okay
okay i'm not notice here in this
headline i'm not getting any details
about what actually happened
here's what i know from the headline the
police killed this woman
and she had a hard childhood okay now
because i'm seeing all these excuses in
the headline i'm going into this and i'm
thinking
this woman must have done something
really bad because if you're
loading up all the excuses and clouding
up all the details in the headline
you know this is whatever this woman did
is really bad
turns out i was right the mother of a 31
year old woman who
died friday after an exchange of gunfire
doesn't say who shot first doesn't say
who pulled the gun first an exchange of
gunfire
with a nashville police officer says her
daughter was wrong for pulling a gun
oh oh you don't say pulling a gun on the
cop well maybe the cop was shooting at
her first
you think that was that nobody thinks
that's what happened but
still in the story it's still possible
that's what happened
but lisa holbert gooch who took in her
niece nico holbert at age
8 and adopted the girl and her younger
siblings said she is disturbed
by the actions of the metro nashville
police officer who stopped holberg
okay well what what's she just she's
saying okay yeah
the girl shouldn't have pulled a gun and
tried to shoot cops but
you know they kind of had it coming
because they had some very disturbing
actions okay what were those actions
gooch questions whether officer josh
baker followed basic traffic stop
safety protocols leading up to the
deadly shooting while police chief john
drake said saturday he believes baker
handled the situation property
she didn't have to die and he didn't
have to get shot gooch said in an
interview
as she watched video of the deadly
incident recorded on baker's body camera
gooch said she was concerned for both
the officer and her daughter
as she saw holbert exiting the vehicle
at the start of the traffic stop
so okay now that we're saying that the
problem here is
that the not that the cop did anything
wrong but that the woman
when she was pulled over at the traffic
stop got out of her car
why was she out of her car gooch said i
don't know that's a question for her
that's not a question for the cops
explaining she's always understood that
police don't typically allow someone to
exit the car as an officer approaches
holbert fled a parking lot friday
morning at the intersection of bridge
church pike and ewing drive
after shooting baker in the torso having
sustained injuries from the gunfire
holbert crashed roughly a block away
before being pronounced dead
so they watched the footage and
then they talk more about this the life
you know and the mother and
that this sort of how terrible it all is
and how unfortunate it all is
gooch said she was stunned to see baker
searching holbert's belongings without
appearing to take precautions
to remain in control of the situation
and after he determined she was not the
man baker was seeking
uh in the first place now what was
happening here
this woman was driving a car that
belonged to a man with outstanding
arrest warrants on felony drug charges
so the guy pulls her over apparently
uh holbert this in the article hobart
repeatedly ignored some of baker's
commands as he attempted to remain
cordial with her the officer declined to
stop her while she went back into the
car multiple times to retrieve various
items
it's like he let her do what she wanted
to do gooch said
the officer is now being accused of
inappropriate behavior
because he gave her the opportunity to
shoot him
that's that was the inappropriate
terrible thing for which this
officer should be investigated is he
wasn't harsh enough with her
now if he had been too harsh there would
be riots right there
if they were too harsh you would have
extortionist organizations like
blm coming down and shaking down
corporate america for tens of millions
more in donations
and you'd hear this that he was a racist
but so he doesn't do that he's actually
too lenient and now this woman and
the newspaper are accusing him
of in inappropriate behavior because he
was too lenient
why'd you let her shoot you how how
wrong of you to let her
shoot you if the races were
reversed the story would not read that
way
that is an institutional sort of racism
that is the sort of thing we see in our
media and it is simply why
when you hear these claims from these
hucksters people like
robin deangelo who is making untold sums
of money
as a race hustler people like ibram
kendy when you hear them talk about
institutional racism
you want to say yes there is there are
institutional racial problems
no question there is affirmative action
right that which disadvantages certain
people
based on their race and gives advantages
to other people solely based on their
race
and there are i mean even beyond that
there are racial issues in the country
no question about it racial issues that
are being inflamed
by people such as deangelo and
kendy and by the mainstream media
which never ever plays fair but it's
because
in this country the absolute worst thing
you can be called is a racist
it's it's why the whole institutional
racism thing
is so important to the left it's why
they're trying to push this
indoctrination
it's the worst thing you can possibly be
called in this country i think that's an
evidence by the way
that it's not a white supremacist
country right is that
the worst thing you could be called is
white supremacist so and the only race
that you're allowed to
smear in public that you're actually
encouraged to are white people and
specifically white guys
right that's why there's no patriarchy
the only group that you're able to smear
is dudes so
you've got all of this built in and it
bleeds into other areas of public policy
as well speaking of law enforcement
challenges we now have a record number
of migrant kids in custody at the
southern border
remember but biden said that
if you voted for trump we're going to
get all these extra kids in cages well
that was true i voted for trump and we
have more kids in cages 300
higher than previously known at the
southern border
but because of our bizarre
racial ideology that the left is pushing
we can't actually deal with this problem
and it's it's harming the people at the
border it's harming those kids and it's
also harming
our country speaking of
difficult challenges and interesting
fights to watch
cardi b is slandering candace's
family candace owens candice really
really taking it in stride and really
wrecking uh poor old cardi b
well if you want more candace owens this
is a great week for you candace no
stranger to controversy she's
got no fear when it comes to speaking
her mind we saw this yesterday as she
renewed her fight with cardi b
uh over the the whap you know and the
wap and whatever uh for more great
entertainment you should tune into her
new
talk show candace starting this friday
march 19th the show will be exclusive to
daily wire members but you can get a new
membership now for 25
off with code candace over at
dailywire.com subscribe
if you want a full recap of the cardi
candace twitter feud join candace
yours truly and the rest of the daily
wire crew tomorrow night
for our latest edition of backstage
which you can watch at dailywire.com
or on the daily wire youtube channel
tune in tomorrow 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m
here in nashville at dailywire.com or
the dailywire youtube channel don't
forget go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candice for 25 off
we'll be right back with a lot more
cbs news reporting that over 13 000
unaccompanied minors are being held in
u.s custody for an average of 120 hours
which is much longer than the 72 hours
permitted by law
more migrants are attempting to cross
into the u.s now than at any time
in the past 20 years this according to
the
secretary of the department of homeland
security
worse than it's ever been on every
single
front whose fault is it gensake why it's
obvious it's trump's fault
there were lawyers who interviewed some
children that were in facilities
the children described sleeping on the
floor being hungry
not being dumping the sun for days how
is that acceptable for the body
administration to keep children
in those sorts of conditions given the
fact that you said you you were in
administration that's going to be more
humane than
the previous one well these let me first
say this is um
heartbreaking uh it's a very emotional
issue for a lot of people
um and it's very difficult and
challenging
and obviously these tbp facilities are
not made for kids
so one of the reasons uh or a driving
reason why
uh the president has pushed to take all
of the actions
that i outlined earlier when phil asked
the question is because we want to
expedite
getting these kids out of these cbp
facilities
as quickly as possible and that's our
goal and our objective and into shelters
as quickly as possible then
into sponsored homes while their cases
are being considered
and adjudicated uh we are trying to work
through
what was a dismantled and unprepared
system because of the
the f the role of the last
administration
hold on we're trying to work through
what was a dismantled and unprepared
system
i thought that the criticism of the past
administration
was that they were too good at putting
kids in cages
i thought the problem was that the
system of border security under trump
was too good
right that it was so inhumane because
they were just nabbing all these kids
and
they weren't letting them go into the
country they were grabbing them and
imprisoning them in cages remember cages
that coincidentally the obama biden
administration built
now you're telling me that the system
wasn't good enough
so it was a lax immigration system which
is it
doesn't matter to them it doesn't matter
which it is they're going to attack
trump
for opposite reasons just like we were
talking about it at the top of the show
you you see the left levying attacks on
the west generally and the church
specifically
for opposite reasons because they just
don't care the arguments aren't the
point
the consequence the effect the attack is
the point
in itself so gensake blaming trump
whoopsie daisy
the the real fault here of course is
lays with the biden administration you
can't blame trump anymore we're now
several months in to the biden
administration and by the way the
original policy
joe biden bears a fair amount of
responsibility for anyway the reporter
to her credit pushes back
i understand the idea of these
facilities not being designed by
children
but children being hungry sleeping on
the floor not being allowed outside for
days at a time
why is that acceptable to go on even for
one more day why is that something
that's not being outlawed right now
how's the administration not stopping
that today well yamiche it's not
acceptable
but i think the challenge here is that
there are only there are not that many
options oh you don't say
you don't say jen saki there are not
that many
options because i remember i'm thinking
way
back in the trump administration
a lot of people come to the border
we then have to figure out what to deal
with them what the left
wanted what they were encouraging trump
to do was just let everybody in but the
law
won't let you do that even if trump
wanted to and it would be a bad idea to
do that but the law won't let you do it
now these kids are often with people who
are posing
as their relatives but who often aren't
their relatives they can be
coyotes they can be just sort of random
people mashed together because they know
that the immigration system goes easier
on
on people who have children with them so
just as the biden administration is
doing you have to vet
who are these adults who are with the
miners
now the adults go to uh
facilities that are administered by the
police right by
cbp by other agencies the children
should not be going to the jails right
you'd i think we all agree on the left
we don't want the children to be sitting
in the jails so the children would go to
places administered by
health and human services but that would
require a separation
and you need a separation anyway because
you've got to vet who these people are
because you don't know because they're
entering your country illegally
what are we going to do then we're going
to send some people back that's not
accepted
we're going to let some people in the
country that's not acceptable either
there aren't that many options so now
not only has the biden administration
not made anything better
the biden administration has made this
situation much
much worse and what does jen saki say
she says look you know it's hard
it's tough and that ultimately i think
all of the biden arguments come back to
that
he isn't doing anything more effectively
or efficient
than president trump and he
has different policy goals but even in
some very basic instances where you have
to have some kind of a border
he's he's not doing any of it better but
he's got better intentions
right that's what jen saki was asked
this a week or two ago she was asked do
you think that
biden has a messaging problem here down
at the border she said
well the past administration
had a morality problem
uh okay but what you know what about
like what's actually happening
like sure i get that you feel
like you're you're on the moral high
ground and you can be very sanctimonious
and you've got the purest of intentions
but lady the road to hell is paved with
good intentions
how come your policies in practice
are so much worse yeah maybe they're
worse in practice but in my intentions
they're really really good so you got to
let us
off the hook not a lot of options i'm so
glad that we can admit that i can't wait
for the apology letters to
file flow into president trump down in
florida
speaking of options
elliot page is an actress
formerly known as ellen page i've never
seen any of her movies
didn't really remember that she existed
but then she got a whole bunch of
publicity
because she decided that now she's a man
and her name is elliot and she's now on
the cover of time magazine
chalk another one up to the white
supremacist patriarchy
you had a lesbian woman who was getting
roles in hollywood who had gotten some
attention
and now all of her roles all of her
attention
going to a straight white man that's
absolutely outrageous isn't it
she writes we know who we are
people cling to these firm ideas about
gender because it makes people feel
safe but if we could just celebrate all
the wonderful complexities of people
the world would be a much better place
i agree with the back part of that if we
could just celebrate all the wonderful
complexities of people the world would
be a much better place
but people like ellen pay elliot page
now
and people who are pushing this
transgender ideology
refuse to deal in the complexities of
people
it is complex when a young
boy behaves in some ways that you might
say are feminine
that is a complexity of lies a
complexity that's always existed and
it's true of just about everybody
it is complex when a woman
has sexual desire for another woman that
is a complex thing because in the normal
course of events a woman would
have sexual desire for men but sometimes
because of the complexity of our world
it's a little different
it is a gross oversimplification
of that complexity to say that if the
boy
ever reaches for a pink t-shirt then
he's really a girl
and you've got to mutilate him and pump
him full of hormones
and make him appear a little bit more
like a girl
that is not complicating our
understanding of human nature
it is simplifying it we know who we are
she says i don't think she does
i don't think any of us do it comes back
though to these heresies that pervade
modern life
it actually comes back to the the sin
that caused the fall of man which is
pride
this idea that i know better than
anybody else
i know human nature better than
aristotle i know
the relationship of the body to the soul
better than saint thomas aquinas
i know the reality of sex better than
um every single person who lived before
like 2004
i i know i know who i am and and it
comes back to this
real error which unfortunately the
reason i mention this here is because
this is an error that pervades our
politics
this error that we own our bodies
we don't own our bodies we did not
create our bodies our bodies are to
borrow a phrase
from rush limbaugh on loan from god
we don't we don't decide when we come
into this world and we're probably not
going to decide how we go out of this
world
we are stewards of this free gift
of creation we are stewards of ourselves
we we have been given this gift of
ourself by god
uh we have intellect we have will and we
have obligations
to our creator
our you don't have to go back to the
middle ages you know to to
see these kinds of ideas
being understood in a widespread manner
you see it in the declaration of
independence
our creator endows us with certain
unalienable rights
and those are wonderful privileges and
as part of that there are certain
obligations and we come together and we
form a polity for these purposes and we
have duty to one another and we
sacrifice and we get these great
privileges hey wonderful
but what elliot page is now referring to
i know who i am i'm really a boy
that is an ancient heresy it's called
gnostic dualism it's the idea
that the body and the soul have nothing
to do with one another so my body i look
like
ellen page looks exactly like a girl but
deep down
somewhere in a non-physical space and
metaphysically
she knows that she is a boy and
therefore she is now a boy
what's so weird though is while the left
is pushing that heresy this idea that
the physical has nothing to do with
reality they're also pushing the
opposite heresy
materialism the idea that we are nothing
more than bags of meat
sort of walking around the streets and
we are nothing more than the sum total
of our desires and our desires are not
rational
they're just pistons firing in our
brains so if it feels good
do it because there's no such thing as a
moral order we're all just stuff
and we're going to die and we're going
to turn to worm food and take a dirt nap
someday
these are opposite heresies they are
mutually exclusive
the left pushes them at the same time
for the same reason that we've been
talking about from the top of the show
because the arguments themselves do not
matter to the left it's only the
final goal which is the upending of
society which
until recently was grounded on the true
understanding
of what human beings are which is body
and soul
inextricably linked in this world the
technical term for it
from old uncle aristotle is hylomorphism
where there's this spiritual component
to who we are this metaphysical
component and there's also this physical
component i do have a body i do live in
space and time
that is the only idea you're not allowed
to hold according to
the radical left these days because
that's that's the only idea
that's true halsey
who i don't i don't know who this is i
think she's a youtuber
uh she is a and a pop singer i don't
know
she's someone who has a blue check mark
and is fairly prominent
she is now changing her pronouns to she
and they she slash they on on social
media bios
and this is receiving a lot of praise i
mentioned this one not not to talk about
it too much only
only because we're now not only
uh having you know he identify as she
we're also having objects identify as
subjects
right we're in in the uh actual uh
uh language jargon we're having the
accusative case
identify as the nominative case because
you'd think if she's gonna do okay she's
she that's like okay she does this
it would be she and them right because
she
usually would be she slash her
but now it's she slash day so now even
that
last rule that you know objects even
that one's gone now
pretty soon the bios will just be blah
blah blah
you can see it advancing in real time
words
are losing their meaning which is
ultimately the goal so that we can't
reason
the orwell writes about this beautifully
in 1984 he says
the the ingsoc regime the big brother
regime thrives
on all sorts of things you know changing
the language through newspeak and the
surveillance
but especially through doublethink the
idea that they will
the regime will force you to hold
mutually contradictory ideas in your
head
at the same time so in your head you've
got to hold the idea that
2 plus 2 equals 4 and 2 plus 2 equals 5.
let's say just to
pull an example out if you hold those
ideas in your head at the same time
it makes you unable and unwilling to
think
rationally if you have to hold the idea
in your mind that
our true selves have nothing to do with
our bodies and
our true selves are just our bodies and
nothing more and you have to hold those
you're headed exactly the same time you
can't think
rationally and that is ultimately
ultimately the goal because what
political correctness or wokism or
cancer culture whatever you want to call
these left-wing
ideologies or left-wing instruments they
are ultimately less about
the arguments they're making than the
imposition of the rules
that's why the pc jargon changes all the
time doesn't really matter which jargon
you're using
it's the imposition of it can these
ideologues
weaken your understanding of the world
so much
that you are vulnerable for them to
impose their will not their intellect
not their arguments but their will on
you speaking of tyrants imposing their
will on you
at least one of those tyrants is about
to face his comeuppance
gavin newsom nussolini governor of my
erstwhile state california was just on
the view
gavin newsom is facing a real recall
challenge we've been reporting on this
every now and again you know
he needed to get one and a half million
signatures or that his opponents needed
to get one and a half million signatures
to recall
him and uh you know force an election
when he had 1.1 million i said maybe
it'll happen they're going to invalidate
a lot of signatures then we get to 1.5
then
two now it's over two and a half million
i believe
he goes on the view to try to burnish
his
pr and his image whoopi goldberg begins
the questioning
now you're in the process of being
recalled by constituents some
constituents who say they have more than
two million signatures
to force a special election against you
now democrats including president biden
are standing by you i want to know as a
former californian person
what is this really about because i
think you've done a pretty damn good job
in this gigantic state of keeping it
together
in in circumstances where you didn't get
a lot of help so what is this really
about and are you concerned
hold on we got to pause it there before
we get to his answer
uh what what was that whoopee were you
have you
i i spent a lot of time in california
this past year before i fled because of
the stupid policies of that guy
in no small part he's
one of the worst governors in the
country the only worst governor would be
andy cuomo and that's not exactly a high
bar
but whoopi she sounds very convincing
right she's just saying look you did a
great job you know and you're
so great gavin newsom just just a
reminder that whoopi goldberg
who i you know in terms of left wingers
i kind of like her
she does this she just says things that
are manifestly not true but she says
them very confidently
and only occasionally does she get
called out for it she was saying this uh
not so long ago
when she was advocating that dr jill
biden
who has an administrative doctorate as a
teacher
should be the surgeon general i'm hoping
dr jill
becomes a surgeon general
joe biden's wife because she's you know
he would never do it but she it's yeah
she's a hell of a doctor
she's an amazing doctor she's a doctor
and phd yeah
i don't i don't know i could be wrong
she's she's a teacher but you know but
you know
but yeah i mean she's a teacher it's
also i don't think it's a phd either i
think it's this
specific sort of administrative
doctorate
uh which would i i don't know if that
qualifies her less or more to perform
surgery but either way she's not
qualified
to do it but the way whoopi does it see
it's kind of convincing because she
doubles down she has no idea what she's
talking about
but she goes yeah i think she should be
the surgeon general whoo and then all
the people in the audience at the view
like yeah she totally should
then it was a joy behar it's like whoopi
are you sure
she's a oh yeah oh she's a hell of a
surgeon oh my gosh she's a gr
she's a hell of a doctor oh she's great
yeah
whoopi i think it i think she's a
teacher
oh i could be wrong well yeah you could
be and you're wrong about gavin newsom
too
all of that a digression gavin what's
your answer uh look i
i appreciate that as you noted correctly
this is the sixth effort and i've only
been in office 25 months
just in 25 months there's been six
efforts to
put a recall on the ballot this one
appears to have the requisite signatures
this started before the pandemic
if you look at the list of grievances
from the proponents of this campaign
it goes to our values it's less about me
it's more about california and our
values democratic party
values issues related to the browning of
california
immigration issues related to low-carbon
green growth
are climate policies issues related to
our advancement
uh to end the you know death penalty or
increase the minimum wage or advance
pay equity and so i say that quite
literally
that's what's at stake in this election
and this recall
guys like me come and go at the end of
the day these principles
are what we're fighting for i love that
his defense is oh no man they've been
trying to recall me from the beginning
oh yeah man they've tried it like six
times i'm such a bad governor
they've been doing this for years the
kovit didn't help you know
but obviously sure they he's a terrible
governor anyway and so they were trying
to recall him
the campaign only took off after covet
that is why
people who are not just republicans
democrats and independents too
are trying to recall him so what he's
trying to do is make this a referendum
on the democratic party agenda
not on his gross incompetence and
so he's saying look it's about the death
penalty you know hey it's about
browning california just making an
explicit racial play right yeah it's
about all that so just you know vote for
me
he might hang on i mean he'll probably
be recalled but he might
he might keep his job in the sense that
he is a crafty politician california
is a blue state and i i wouldn't count
the guy out
yet same thing with cuomo cuomo right
now i've been saying it from the
beginning i said this guy
doesn't look good for him you know maybe
he's out but
but if anyone can hold on it's andy
cuomo there's a sienna college poll
released on
on monday saying that 35 of new yorkers
want andrew cuomo to resign just
35 percent even after all this it's only
35 percent
most importantly here only 25 of
self-identified democrats
want cuomo to resign six in 10 democrats
and half of all new yorkers think that
cuomo should not resign and that's why
cuomo is making this play he's saying
i wasn't elected by the politicians i
was elected by you the people
and that's why i it's not even like i'm
just doing a generic new york the the
actual cuomo accent is more it's kind of
like more like
uh al pacino and the godfather one it's
a little bit higher
a little softer but regardless of
his uh the way he says it what he is
saying is
that he's going to make an appeal to the
people not to the politicians
and as i mentioned at the time when
everyone was laughing at him
it's a good play in new york there is
actually a chance he might survive it
a big day in new york is saint patty's
day because there are a lot of irish
people in new york
i actually despite my appearance i'm a
quarter irish
i i know i don't necessarily look at i i
do identify that way though and i am
actually a quarter irish my culture
is not your costume folks when you go
out and get hammered today and you throw
on green
you know green shirts and hats and stuff
and start punching each other in the
street
and just slamming beers left and right i
want you to know
my culture is not your costume okay
but i probably you're not going to hear
any complaints about the cultural
appropriation of the irish
because of course it is a not just a
double standard
it's an absolutely frivolous political
strategy
and maybe when we notice that when we
see everyone you know guzzling beer and
punching each other today on saint
patty's day and no one's going to
talk about cultural appropriation maybe
we can realize the rest of it is bs too
it's just a weapon it's an instrument
to divide us and i think it would be
worthwhile
if we could overcome our fear of being
called racists and this system that is
and stand up against that kind of stuff
because it
is a vicious strategy it's anti-american
but it's working i'm michael knowles is
the michael show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show